you're friends with DiCaprio and like
yeah what does that mean what does that
look like and how does that happen
believe it or not from men's league
basketball one of my boys who's from L.A
loves my comedy he runs the new stand on
Sunset Boulevard so he grew up with like
Leo and like Toby Maguire like in this
La scene so he's at the comedy store and
I swear he's like yo we need a fifth do
you can you play ball and the team is
Leonardo DiCaprio Kevin Connolly Lucas
Haas Nick cassavettes and it's like 80
million dollars worth of talent is about
to play basketball and so just from
playing Bell playing ball every week we
just developed like a friendship with
all is Leo good at basketball he doesn't
he had a good post up move he wasn't a
jump not a great job no no he could play
but he had like come out of Basketball
Diaries and you could tell that he was
coached on like a couple basic solid
moves for years I just got a front row
seat to like the craziest most fun time
you could ever ask for